during the 2008 presidential campaign
michelle obama was asked on the tonight
show about the cost of her wardrobe
[Music]
actually this is a j crew ensemble
really wow
j.crew clothing would become a staple in
the former first lady's wardrobe
elevating the brand's image from preppy
basics to professional
yet affordable chic but recently the
apparel brand has struggled with
slumping sales and a debt load that
ultimately led the retailer to seek
bankruptcy protection
in court filings the company cited
losses incurred because of coronavirus
lockdowns but analysts say the brand
also lost touch with consumers with
styles that appeared more suited for the
runway
than for everyday life here's how j.crew
filed for bankruptcy
j.crew formerly known as popular
merchandise inc
emerged in 1983 as a catalog only
retailer
it offered a pioneering line of casual
fashion built on affordable weathered
chinos and simple crewneck t-shirts
well they were really the preppy chic
brand
sort of preppy with a twist the kind of
clothes that you know you could wear to
the office but also the perfect
weekend clothes the brand opened its
first retail store in 1989
and over the next decade found its home
in malls across the country
many of the brand styles can be
attributed to jenna lyons
who was first hired as a designer in
1990.
her design influence grew the brand by
attracting both luxury
and middle-class customers former gap
ceo mickey drexler joined the company in
2003
and promoted lines to creative director
a few years later
mickey drexler was best known for
turning gap into a cultural icon in the
1990s
he came to j crew and sort of had a
second act
and jenna lyons was sort of his creative
right hand
woman so to speak she turned things like
sequins where
you would think would you only wear sort
of out on a saturday night you know all
of a sudden you could
you know wear them during the day and
she kind of really glammed up the brand
in 2006 drexler founded the successful
companion brand madewell
j crew also went public that same year
only to be taken private again five
years later
in a leveraged buyout that saddled the
company with debt
not too long after sales began to flag
starting in 2014 j
crew experienced six straight years of
losses and the company
started looking for ways to cut back and
attract new customers
well they started to get a bit too glam
and that this is where some of the
critics started blaming jenna that
her style became to brooklyn for their
kind of j cruz mainstream
customers and then on top of that they
ended up with quality
and fit problems you know the quality
became inconsistent
customers kind of just lost faith in the
brand
in 2017 with the company still
floundering lions departed and drexler
stepped down as ceo
and the brand narrowly avoided
bankruptcy as part of a controversial
debt swap
that moved its intellectual property
beyond the reach of creditors
they were just caught a little bit
flat-footed and didn't act fast enough
to
you know um develop e-commerce to
develop
you know all the things now that we sort
of expect from a retailer
heading into 2020 j.crew planned to
raise cash by spinning off its madewell
chain through an ipo but plans came to a
halt as coronavirus lockdowns forced the
retailer to close some 500 stores
in court filings the brand said it
expected to lose 900 million dollars in
sales because of lockdowns
putting it in a position where it
couldn't pay its debts
on may 4th 2020 j.crew filed for
bankruptcy
you know j crew has a smaller footprint
than a lot of other retailers
and they didn't overexpand so that's
positive for them
they are in a position where they're not
going to probably have to close
hundreds of stores they also have a new
ceo
and you know her mission was sort of to
restore the brand to its former glory
you know getting back to the quality and
the fit that
customers loved and kind of the classic
styles
as the retailer looks to navigate its
way out of bankruptcy
it will also try to recapture customers
who once looked for clothes that could
be worn on any occasion
even inauguration day